[Music]
hmm
there is not a soul on the earth who
would wait for you
as i have
you know i'm starting to get used to
these little meanings
i sense you have many questions i may
answer
only one
who are you and why do you keep
disappearing
you can only ask one question
you cannot climb on two separate trees
at once
are you [ __ ] serious
cursing also cleanses the soul
are you ready for the final meditation
technique
the last one
yes it will cost however much you want
hope this'll do i will guide you through
the meditation
[Music]
this is a meditation of the air element
we are in the mountains heading toward
the peak
we squeeze between two boulders
on the first boulder sits an eagle the
spirit of the air passes through every
fiber of this eagle
spirit of the air primordial wind
i send you greetings we are of one blood
you and i you are within me
and i am within you without you
life would not last even a few minutes
so vital are you to us
oh great spirit of the air please
cleanse my body and soul relinquish pain
sickness the negative energy from
negative
people worlds and dimensions
give me the energy of life give me
health wisdom knowledge
strength joy happiness
and lasting inner peace
i am an eagle the wind cushions my wings
caresses my feathers enters every fiber
of my body
fills the spaces of every atom and
molecule
the wind cleanses the body the soul
and the subtle body
circling upwards we rise up high
we feel lightness purity
joy our body is filled with happiness
peace and harmony
we thank you spirit of the air with our
mind
body and soul
and he is gone
at least he left something
[ __ ] i feel like a dog's [ __ ] you see
that
there was a zen master here and poof
you vanished like that the [ __ ] are you
talking about
you taught me how to meditate it was
kind of weird it's not my scene
go and talk to to misty if it bothers
you
yeah good idea